I've got I've got an announcement for
everybody
the message Bud Light has for you is
that if you drink their beer you are gay
and I'm not being tongue-in-cheek Bud
Light sponsors Cincinnati Pride Parade
after Dylan Mulvaney controversy the
reason why I say it that way is
after the controversy already put Bud
Light in this position where they were
viewed as a beer for the LGBT community
Bud Light decided you know what whatever
Double Down sponsor a pride event and
that's fine they're allowed to do
whatever they want you know whatever
that just like
they I think they've decided you know
what embrace it just go right with it
they are officially the beer for the
LGBT community I don't know why you're
laughing like they're just that's the
route they're going I I respect it you
know why
when they sponsored domovanian try and
Hammond Hall and play this stupid game
of no no oh wait no we didn't mean it
but not actually apologizing not
actually saying anything I'm just like
dude you can't have your cake and eat it
too you can't make a Clydesdale
commercial with 911 stuff in it and then
do this at the same time so then they
lie low for a little bit then they
sponsor Pride they're basically coming
out and being like this is the route
we've decided to go we want to be a
niche beer for a small community and I
can respect it I think they're looking
at their brand and they're being like
Bud light's done let's pass it on to
this community who likes it and make
money with the core base that's
substantially smaller than the General
market and then focus on something else
I do think it's funny that uh Budweiser
sponsored or was was sponsored by or
partnered with Harley-Davidson because
they're like okay here's the plan
Budweiser is manly and Bud Light is gay
I see what they're doing there well no
it's not a joke I don't know why you're
laughing
it's just literally what they're doing
look man load the bases right get get
everybody out there
oh yeah this is a picture and then all
you gotta do is hit a single and you're
making money they talk about how they're
doing the the the uh camo cans or
whatever I saw that for veterans yep but
then they go and do this and it's like I
don't I don't think they look dude they
don't care about you they don't care
about you they don't care about your
values they're just like I don't know
man we want to make money
so this is it this this news
um this is what because it's coming out
today right I think so yeah this news is
breaking
yeah on a Friday so we're after hours I
got I gotta I gotta look man I think
their stock is gonna drop bad oh yeah if
their stock already took a major hit
from this and they doubled down I can't
imagine how their stock recovers are you
talking about Bud Light right yeah
Anheuser Anheuser Anheuser in general
but but again it's not even so much as
to whether or not this will impact sales
it's that you have a major Scandal major
Scandal people stop buying stock drops
then as the stock is going bad you
engage in the same practice that
resulted in the boycott in the first
place I have to imagine anybody holding
Anheuser stock at this point going oh
man I tried to hold that I'm and just
sells
I wouldn't be surprised if their stock
drops by like 20 like 15 points in the
next few days and the Memorial Day
rebate too it's even worse when they're
basically giving away free beer because
it's more expensive to you know send it
back and throw it away the Ruby is
hilarious yeah it is three comical thing
ever because people were joking about it
they're like we can't give it away for
free at this point and then two weeks
later it was an actual campaign so it's
beyond comical
it's pretty funny I think it does make
more sense to just pick a route and take
it though than to try to please everyone
because then there's always going to be
the group who's like well I don't like
that they're doing the pride stuff and
then there's going to be the ads that
are like manly men that are going to
clash and it's never going to please the
whole customer base there's there's been
first for for the longest time for this
a significant portion at least of my
life there has been an incentive for
companies to avoid politics yeah because
then you're you know Michael Jordan said
it best Republicans buy sneakers too
yeah that's the way it was from the 80s
pardon me but yeah I've been Legend it
really shouldn't matter either it's
crazy to see how many big companies are
deciding to make that like a Forefront
of their advertisements well I mean I I
think it's because of the ESG stuff
because the the point is if you have if
you're a stakeholder that they call it
stakeholder capitalism if you have a
stake in these companies if you're a
stakeholder even if you lose money on
this particular investment there are
opportunities that will be made for
people that have for companies that have
a high enough ESG score so you may lose
money here but down the road there will
be opportunities and essentially what
it's gonna what it seems like is gonna
turn into is a way to lock people out
that don't have a high enough ESG score
it's a social Credit Credit system but
for companies
so if you don't have a high enough ESG
score you don't get the opportunities
you don't get the you don't get the the
chance to bid on this contractor you
don't get the chance to do this job you
don't get the chance to do this so
whereas there might be companies that
lose money in the beginning when they
you know do something that's unpopular
over time it's fine because companies
that don't play along will be shut out
so it's a social credit course there's
credit course starting with companies
and it'll eventually move down to the
population because there are people that
have been unbanked you know kicked out
of the banking system and stuff that is
a real thing it is straight up maoism
coming to America yeah they already lost
like points on their their corporate
equality index thing it says Anheuser
did uh yeah they had a perfect 100 score
and uh they it doesn't say what it's
decreasing to but they got a letter from
the Human Rights Campaign saying that
it's they're going to decrease their
score well the Human Rights Campaign
keeps score I guess well I keep
suggestions now on too it's the America
score and I give Anheuser-Busch a minus
50. the worst score you could you could
get because -50 is where we stop for
some reason well what are they losing
points for the putting the VP on lead
because yeah I think I think because
they kind of distance themselves the
non-apology type thing but but it was
offensive enough to that that's what's
what Target is doing too yeah well let's
put this stuff in the back of the store
he straight up said hide this from our
customers but then tell everyone else
that we're still on their side it was it
was like
amazingly offensive to everyone I was
really impressed by that that's what I
was saying they try to please everyone
they piss everyone off he wasn't trying
to please everybody it like
would you be like hey I'm on your side
Alx we're gonna put that Benny Johnson
book on the floor so nobody can see it
that's an insult that's not that's not
defending you're like uh okay it's it's
like it's like acting like it's it's
it's it's how you insult someone
tongue-in-cheek so are they being
boycotted by leftists now too because of
that you know what I think happened is
they said that they had incidents in the
South or whatever yeah yo I bet they
went into some like very conservative
areas and their targets and they put a
bunch of Pride stuff and I bet people
walked in and you know we hear these
stories about confrontations and threats
and stuff
the people on the right are like no that
didn't happen like concerns dude I don't
think it was conservatives I told this
to Wesley hunt the other day
I think regular people snapped I think
some dude walked in with his kid down in
Alabama or something his little
four-year-old daughter to get to get a
pack of beer and he walks in and he sees
it and he's like what the you doing I
got my kid here man and then probably
yelled and they I think there's stuff we
just didn't see yeah Benny did a video
yesterday he was literally at a Target
in Tampa yesterday and it's still right
in the front oh yeah yeah like so there
was it really depends on the city yeah
they said in the south
at the one in in uh Martinsburg Target
it's right out front it was been there
I've been boycotting it was it was like
five days ago or something yeah I
wouldn't be surprised if it stayed I
definitely I think I it was a video like
on Twitter I can't remember who posted
it but it was some guy like tearing down
the pride side which like that's that's
not cool that's vandalism don't do that
yeah it was captioned terrorism yeah and
I was like I don't know about terrorism
well that's what I mean posted though
the old Summer of Love videos it's
because it wasn't that it was that's
what I was saying it was in response to
that yeah because when I saw this oh
this is I almost fell for it that that
was real but I was like this looks too
familiar yeah Adrian Curry said my
friend works at Target in Joliet
Illinois and people freaked out in the
store
wow I can see that I'm being from uh
Chicago and we used to hang out in
Joliet periodically I mean also hi
Adrian
come back anytime we've had so many
killer shows in Joliet Illinois no
kidding around seriously like I I
haven't been there in a very long time
it's probably been 15 years
but my view of the people down there are
like they're I don't know how do you
describe it
it's hard to describe
without being insulting I say this is a
term of endearment white trashy yeah you
know because like I'm a South Side like
we were South Side white trash ish I
mean we're like a mixed family or
whatever but like we lived in this area
where everybody was kind of just poor
working class white people
and
I I can imagine people in Joliet being
like get this out of here man like we
have kids
but I don't know times change I don't
know Juliet's like these days the forge
in Julia it's the place that we play
it's awesome they got a prison down
there too yep oh yeah that's the uh
that's where ink in the clink is that's
where the um I think no I mean I could
be wrong no no State Prison apparently
it's really bad yeah but anyway the CEO
of Target is like we want to let you all
know that we're here we're on your side
and we still do support you we're just
putting you in the back so that nobody
can see you but when you when uh what
you said you said the one out here was
still in the front
uh yes the well the one in Martinsburg
and this was a couple days ago so I'm
not sure if the in you know the
intensity had gotten to the point where
they're like oh we got to get it out of
here um I don't remember exactly what
day I went in there's the other day but
it was when I when I went in yeah and
they still had plenty of Pride stuff out
you know
West Virginia
second most Trump supporting country
um Trump supporting state in the country
it's not a country itself uh and I got
to tell you there's a lot of woke stuff
in West Virginia it's weird it's I
really think it's because the companies
have you know have I mean it's it's
there is a lot of pressure from groups
like BlackRock and and like the Human
Rights Campaign and and all these
non-governmental organizations and and
stuff that are that are trying to get
companies to behave in a certain you
know a certain way it's it's like it's
as if the Marxist realized that if you
go into a society of via capitalism
that'll work because that's what
happened in China yeah you know China
was incredibly poor until they start
until Deng Xiaoping opened up markets
and that made China you know capable of
flourishing thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time